so  alex the day's finally here  you've been at the helping hands group  home for eight years  we've been through a lot in that time  we have and now you're finally leaving  to live with your brother  my brother gabe it says here he lives in  haven springs colorado  is that correct that's a big move  do you have any plans as far as school  or a job  my brother said i might pick up a few  shifts at the bar he works at  so you'd be dealing with people  maybe  does your brother know about your issues  is that an official interview question  dr lin  alex you know that i care about you  with everything that has happened  i just want what's best for you  he doesn't know  no one will once i leave this place  i'll just be a normal girl  in a normal town  [Music]  you